edwards that game already expanding in  his rookie year and he hits the three  the rainbow three for anthony edwards  number one pick playing like yeah lebron  lined up  you know sometimes just shooting it's  the better  choice is he'll get into double digits  what's coos doing with it hatching it  that's exactly right  lakers win it tonight and they're coming  home  to face brooklyn on thursday one of the  marquee matchups  of the season and boy lebron giving some  love to the number one pick and i'm sure  that means a ton  to anthony oh come on he grew up  watching everything saying i hope he's  in the league  when i get there and not